my guest tonight appeared in the indie
hit movie dope and the amazon series
transparent
starting friday you can see her in the
new psychological
thriller antebellum please welcome
kersey
clemens kirsty you look amazing you look
funny hi you look amazing i love your
hair
all right well let's talk about our hair
because both of us decided to go for it
right in in the covid quarantine
um i have decided to just let it go
i'm having all kinds of issues with my
hair i think it looks
good i like it you're giving me like a
surfer um situation
yeah i'm the a really pale surfer who's
never been to the beach
that's never been in the sun a day in
yeah and look at that it's just like
it's getting real crazy but it gets in
my eyes how about you what are you
experiencing now that you've gone for it
well my hair doesn't get in my eyes
because my hair grows in this direction
um but i mean i feel like every time i'm
on your show my hair is longer and
longer
yeah that's no i was baldwin yeah yeah i
mean
it's beautiful what you got going on any
concerns though because
i have found that this is more
maintenance in some ways are you finding
that at all
i normally just i mean it is maintenance
if i don't do anything
it like locks up the other day a spider
fell from my hair and landed on my face
and that's my biggest fear is
in my hair so your fear is that insects
will live inside your hair
one hundred percent like when i'm
outside and there's a bee i'm like it's
gonna fly into my hair
get lost get stuck or like a i'm afraid
that like
bugs are going to lay eggs yeah
it's okay we all have our own concerns i
saw
two days ago a labrador retriever puppy
fell out of my hair i mean there's all
kinds of stuff
i've got my i've got my taxes in here uh
from 1988 to 1997.
i'm filing stuff in here it's gotten out
of control
how are you handling last time we talked
you were very
uh candid about twitter and how
you've been having some issues with your
twitter account because
like some of us you like to have a drink
or two and then get on twitter
and that can lead to issues i've deleted
my twitter account
you deleted it yeah on my own merit like
no one told me kirsten you should get
off twitter i just deleted it
i just it's so much going on
and it's toxic or something high school
yeah i can't i can't do it i think i
think you're
i think you have the right approach you
described
twitter uh recently as being stuck at a
bad
party is that how it feels to you 100
i realized when i was saying it too that
now you don't get stuck at parties
because we have
like chauffeurs on our phones
but when i was in high school i would
always
my friends were so bad i was the good
kid i just want to be clear
and we would they'd be like it's fine
girl like he's gonna drive us to the
party he doesn't drink
it's gonna be all good and then we get
there and we're stuck
he's doing drugs not drinking but he
might as well be
right and then he's not get the party
you're like i don't want to be here i
hate everybody here
and i keep coming back every weekend and
that's what twitter feels like to me
every time i'm there i'm like why did i
come back and i'm stuck right
that sounds that sounds rough kirsty let
me tell you what my experience was
nobody invited me to a party
nobody no that's the thing nobody was
ever invited to the party
it's not it's not a part of your your
anyone's invited to it's like a party
that ends because you hear gunshots
those yeah
that's that's different okay yeah yeah
no i
didn't different high school we went to
it sounds like i sound
well first of all we went to different
high schools but i think uh and
i will be honest with you there were no
gunshots
uh going off in brookline massachusetts
let me say that
but at the same time at the same time
if i had gone to your high school guess
what no one would have invited me to a
party
that's i would have i would have invited
you
you would have invited me and maybe you
could have been the designated driver
and i wouldn't feel the way that i feel
if you had invited me to the party
people would have said why'd you bring
that weird white lady with you
at the party what's with the weird old
white lady
what is she doing here you know what's
funny
i gotta say i always have such a great
time talking to you
and then i saw recently that you
described yourself as an introvert and i
thought
i talked to kearsey all the time i've
talked to her
she's fantastic you are a great
interview you've got so much personality
you don't come across as an introvert
because i'm
the thing about introverts is when we're
at home we're practicing how to be human
out in the real world
so i just you know i work on my hi
hi hey you know it gets more casual in
the beach hey
sure okay how's it going so i work on it
i work on how to socialize
um think and i'm an actor so i'm faking
it i don't even want to be here you know
talking to me right now is a living hell
that's what you're saying
it's torturous i have no pants on i
don't like it oh
okay well all right well we've got that
in common uh
and and you've got spiders maybe in your
hair you don't know i do
you know what's so funny and i have to
bring this up because i thought it was
hilarious
this whole time i thought i just like
misheard and i thought that you were in
nigeria this whole time
because i thought you were in lagos
no that would first of all that would be
so cool
quarantining in nigeria i'm at the largo
theater
l-a-r-g-o in los angeles very famous old
theater
but i love that you thought wow conan's
quarantining in nigeria
i literally thought oh my god he cares
about the theaters in nigeria like
he took his whole team to lagos that's
crazy
and then yesterday i realized oh
he's in like west hollywood look there
are a lot of similarities
okay they would say
[Laughter]
i want to talk a little bit about your
personal life if that's cool i think
this is really neat
that your your girlfriend is her name
ebony
yeah her your girlfriend ebony was your
stunt devil or still is your stunt
double
yeah there's two funny things about
ebony she's my stunt double
and we look nothing alike we're just
like the same complexion
um and she's white which is really funny
when we go out to eat
because she'll put down her card
um and people will assume that i've paid
because i look like my name is ebony
you know what i never get i never get
that i never get that
no one ever is like and you're ebony uh
no conan yeah
and they're like there's no way that
this one is ebony we're gonna go with
that one
yeah uh she's beautiful we got
she's beautiful you guys are a gorgeous
couple i hate how big the photo
you know what's sick i've had this photo
for a while
i i carry i just have this around and
every now and then i'm just like
yeah they're beautiful yeah yeah thanks
yeah that doesn't look that's not a good
look for me to get like get pulled over
and they're like what are you doing with
this
i think that's a very great that's your
support for the lgbtqia plus
totally yes thank you thank you i'm
going to have this on me
no it's it's uh she is absolutely
uh beautiful and i'm told that she is
quite handy around the house that she's
yeah
she does everything around here she
obviously like i just said pace for
dinner so there's that um
she has been building making me day beds
uh really she can build stuff yeah
we have like a breakfast nook now she
just took up carpentry during covid
which is wild because i took up nothing
um no who does that who takes it apart
she sounds like a
a superhero i mean to take up carpentry
during coven and be like okay i'm going
to build you a breakfast nook
yeah and we never even eat breakfast
there so
i'm a [ __ ] bag can i say [ __ ]
yes that's okay yes you can that's all
right
i'm asking the sensors right now in
nigeria and they're saying it's
gone right what are the rules in nigeria
very different they don't mind that word
but they're they get very upset about
other words so
yeah um now is so
if ebony is pretty much a carpenter now
mm-hmm yeah whatever do you give her
like gifts
do you give her i got her a table saw um
and bought her a bunch of wood so that
she can make my stuff
so that's what you do in partnerships
right you like
get them guess what i've been married
for 18 years my wife never given me a
table saw or any kind of tool because
she knows i'm an idiot
and i i can't use it yeah i mean she
knows your strengths and weaknesses at
this point
so fair enough is it
is this true that um i i was told that
you gave
your girlfriend a cardboard cutout of
yourself
uh that sounds like the most
egotistical thing i've ever heard and a
great idea
hey i was when we were doing long
distance and so
i was going to send her a cardboard cut
out of like
you know her celebrity crush or
something
um and i was seeing my friends on
amazon as cardboard cutouts and i was
like maybe i
am on here and so i was
which is so wild that's great yeah
yeah so i ordered her a cardboard cut
out of myself and
i mean that's like romance yes well also
it's a sign that you've really made it
when you can go on amazon and they
already have a cardboard cut out of you
kiersey clements ready to go that means
you've made it dog
hello hello i want to talk about
antebellum because
i called it a sort of a psychological
thriller this is
a fascinating idea for a movie
disturbing on so many levels
um but really beautifully done and
we want to show a clip of it but i want
to make sure i don't give away too much
because there's so many twists and turns
in antebellum
people have to see it they gotta watch
it uh but i wanna make sure that we
don't tell
too much so i wanna turn it over to you
what can you tell us about antebellum
that uh you think i mean first of all it
feels like
very of the moment and also just a very
just a powerful story
yeah i mean i can't really say much
without completely uh
taking away like the most exciting part
of the movie
which is this i think like a genre
bending
film and i think that
you get lost in each act which is really
cool you think you're watching one movie
and it turns into another and
i think that's important for people to
know before
they watch it because it it really is
like this
it's a storytelling experience you know
yeah yeah it really is we have a clip
here
anything you want to tell us about the
clip before we show it
um no good okay i mean
i actually i think that's fair because i
i don't this is such an interesting
movie
and i'm i mean it's in the best way i
think the less said the better
i really think people should yeah i
think so too all right let's take
let's take a look at this clip from
antebellum cool
i know you
i know that you are my only way out of
here
i need you to listen to me
you have to keep quiet these white
people will
kill you oh you think being quiet is
being strong huh
what has that ever gotten us all right
i'm excited uh annabellum
is available at home on demand and it's
available
this friday and people watch this it's
really fantastic
kirsty i love talking to you i really do
you are i love talking to you thank you
for having me on and always being so
nice to me i really do appreciate you
be safe uh continue to take care of
yourself and i can't wait to see you in
person sometime soon
yeah that'd be nice um thank you so much
thank you kersey take care